senate democrats plan to start debating
on a new voting rights bill and they
will try to change senate rules to get
this thing passed although we got to
point out it is not likely to happen
because of opposition from all 50
republicans plus two democrats but for
more on all of it let's go to ed o'keefe
at the white house ed good morning what
do we know
good morning tony as you said senate
expected to begin formal debate on the
legislation later today and while it's a
top democratic party priority the
president's struggling to convince
members of his own party to change the
rules and get it done
activists have spent the last few days
trying to rally support for new voting
reform legislation and so has president
biden it's about two insidious things
voter suppression
and election subversion the legislation
would establish national early voting
and vote by mail standards make election
day a national holiday and require
certain states to get clearance from the
justice department before making changes
to local election laws what they want to
do is just basically have the federal
government take over all elections in
the united states it comes as at least
19 mostly republican-controlled states
have passed restrictive voting laws in
the last year and no gop senator is
expected to support the voting rights
bill what is the benefit of actually
holding the vote one of the two major
political parties in america has now
said
that it is their policy
to win by keeping american citizens from
voting and by
we ought to put them on the record make
them vote on that but republicans aren't
the only problem while democrats kirsten
cinema of arizona and joe manchin of
west virginia support the legislation
they don't support scrapping a rule
requiring that at least 60 senators
agree to hold a final vote on the bill
civil rights activists are hoping to
change their minds senator cinema
senator mansion
our future hinges on your decision and
history will remember what choice you
make
now you might be wondering why is the
president focused on this issue of
defeat is almost completely certain
we'll take a look at this new cbs news
poll we asked americans is the buying
administration focused too much just
about enough or not enough on the issue
of voting rights and access turns out
one third say the bind administration is
focused on the issue about the right
amount four and 10 say he's not focused
on it enough that's a sign that even in
the face of defeat
giving the americans are going to give
him credit for at least trying
tony yeah it's a reason to get on the
record ed thank you very much